okay let's get started so welcome my
name is Stephen Kelly I'm going to talk
to you about embracing modern sea Mike
it's always a nice thing to have so many
people in one room who all have very
positive feelings about see Mike so who
has positive feelings about see Mike put
up your hand I'm actually surprised that
many yeah a lot of people don't like see
make see Mike has been around for a long
time it has a lot of cruft and you do
hit into it and you do see it in code
that other people have written so I want
to tell you about modern sea make what
that is where it came from and how you
can recognize the difference so a little
bit about my background I've been
writing C++ code and open source for
about 10 years starting out in KDE with
KML and Katie pimp getting into the
libraries and then therefore getting
into cute and into see Mike so I vote
the see make integration that shipped
with cute 5 and I thought well see make
isn't good enough so I started working
on see Mike then as well more recently
I've been working a bit on clang and
clang tidy just to help you refactor
your code a little bit better more more
mechanically so that's kind of how I got
from doing Katie work to doing see Mike
work and creating modern see Mike so see
make is a build system generator that's
you know it's not so much related to
make and that make invokes you compiler
but see Mike generates other stuff which
then in turn invokes your compiler it
stands for cross-platform make because
that was what was relevant back in 2000
when it was created different make
systems existed but these days see make
also generates your build files for
ninja and for Visual Studio and for
Xcode and actually for some other
systems too it's part of a larger suite
of productivity and test tools such as C
test and C pack I'm not going to be
talking about those but they integrate
very well with scene
if you're using CMake already
here's just a plot of see my
contributors over the last two years I
just kind of like to show this kind of
thing to show where say makers coming
from along the bottom you see Brad King
he's the maintainer of see Mike you have
use everything does a great job and
above that you see all these
contributions from all the other people
but this is the last two years I'm
actually going to go back to about four
years ago and this is me creating modern
C mix so I want to just show this
because it shows you how old modern C
make actually is so it's so old that
even you're going to 1604 system already
has a modern and off C make to do
everything that I'm going to show in
this presentation so just to sort of set
the set the scene a little bit when I'm
talking about a build system I'm talking
about the stuff that you're a building
from source and I have a dotted line
around that and that can include various
libraries that you're building and
executables and there could be
dependencies between them the Nightside
of dotted box there's other stuff so
your external dependencies it could be
cute
boost you know google photo buff
anything but what i'm going to mostly be
talking about is the stuff inside of
this box so you're creating some
libraries and some executables and those
things depend on each other where cemex
shines is in finding dependencies
there's a lot of cross-platform reliable
ways to find external dependencies such
as cute and boost it also excels in
portability in that you can use it with
very various build system generators as
I already mentioned visual studio and
make code generation you can define
custom commands and custom targets for
example to generate your mock foe code
in a cute program
there's also multi-language support this
keeps growing
I think we've got C sharp and Swift
support in C make now as well so if you
have a multilingual build system see
Mike cannot handle a tune so modern C
make is it's kind of a mindset it's a
little bit philosophical in that sense
and what it aims to do is get you
writing less code or less see my code
have that code be more clean and dry
don't repeat yourself and have you seen
my code be more target focused and not
you know this sort of if you get this
right the other stuff just follows from
that if you get your code target focused
it'll automatically be more clean and
you'll have less of it so I mentioned
this already but the good news is that
everything I'm showing you you can
already use so I think everything in
this presentation is present in C make
3.1 in Eastern December 2014 and present
on traverse for a long time Debbie and
Jesse and at least you've been to 1604
I'm going to show you some other stuff
that was introduced in to 811 already so
even if you're still depending on 1204
there's some things in this presentation
that you'll still be able to use so
hello world well maybe a few steps above
hello world see Mike build system might
look like this what we have is were
defining the minimum version that we
depend on a project name define a
library called Lib salutation which
consists of salutation dot CPP we then
also have an executable called hello
which is built from hello dot CPP and we
say that hello links to live salutation
so you can just kind of imagine that
hello dot CPP is somehow going to use
the functionality from web salutation
and just to add a little bit more
interesting this and complexity
goodbye dot CPP is built into goodbye
executable and that also depends on
their salutation so this isn't too
complicated we're just defining three
different targets and two of them depend
on the library and this is not about
start but let's look closer at this line
number one because it's often overlooked
and people don't really know what it
means I think so let's talk about
policies when we have a Simo see make
minimum required line it specifies a
version and that has a couple of
meanings that'll cause you see make
executable to fail at one time if your
version is lower than version 2.8 it'll
also populate a variable so you can test
in your seam a code what the minimum
required version is you might want to do
that if you're going to guard the use of
newer features if they're available for
example it also resets runtime behavior
see make with policies and this is what
I want to talk about essentially what
our policies so policies are a system
built in to see make for deprecating old
behavior often if we hit a bug in c make
will create a policy so that we maintain
the boogie behavior but we also have new
behavior which is more sane and will
give you a warning if you're
accidentally depending on the old
behavior that might mean something like
the link order is incorrect on your
command line that we generate and so
we'd have a policy for you know
generating the correct link order small
policies are in the warned state by
default and you can set them
individually every time that you have AC
make minimum required line that is
associate
with a newest policy so if I say that my
see make minimum is 3.3 policy 57 and
below will all be set to new behavior
instead of the old behavior and similar
if I say the minimum required is 3.2 but
let's see 55 and below will be set to
new behavior and all the others will be
old behavior and everything newer will
be worn so here's how you would set a
policy individually you use the C make
policy command and you set it to new if
it's if it's available so you can test
whether a policy is available policy 53
is a policy which changed how C make
parses your C make file that changed how
variables are processed it actually
created a large speed improvement in her
variables are processed but because it
had a slight behavior change we ought to
create a policy for it and it was
introduced after a 3.0 so if my minimum
was cuidado it's worn by default so I
said it explicitly to new it is possible
to set a policy to old you almost never
want to do that if you're setting a
policy to old that is a good indication
that you are not using modern C make so
when you would set a policy to old
here's a few conditions that you'd want
to satisfy before doing that you might
want to do it if you're close to your
own release but a new C Mac version has
just been released and that's warning on
your code and you don't want to have
those warnings when your clients are
building your code so you would set the
policy to old in that case but even if
you do you do want to have a plan to
migrate the new behavior of the policy
and one of the reasons for that kind of
you know it reaches C++ developers
sometimes if you can put things in terms
of performance any policy which exists
will
a cost of implementing the old behavior
and there will be a cost of implementing
the new behavior so say in the case of
policy 53 the old slow way of parsing
variables and the new faster way but by
default if that thing is worn setting
it'll actually do both and it'll compare
the output so being extra overhead in
order to give you the warning so you
want to always make sure that you set
policies to new if if your build system
can handle it but just in terms of how
that code would look you would just use
C make policy to set the policy to old
and you would you would do that even
though the version is much newer so you
use a new version to get new features
but then you set the policy to old to
get old behavior in that specific case
but usually what you would do is you
would have a list of policies that you
get warnings about but which actually
you want the new behavior for and you
set up a loop and you'd say if the
policy exists set it to new and you
would be able to remove this code once
that your version is so high that those
policies have already said to you so
you'll see this in a lot of modern
cinema code there are some policies
which don't warn you by default here's
the list of them they don't warn by
default because there would be too many
warnings but you can just know that they
exist and if you get strange behavior
you can try to enable them and see if
that helps so what I'm trying to do in
this talk is just give you a list of
guidelines that you can take back to
your office on Monday and use them to
implement modern CMAC so the first one
is use of today's policy settings in
your code I see a lot of code online on
github etc
where they say see make minimum version
2.8 and that means 2.0 which was
released about ten years ago and every
policy since then is said to warn so you
don't want to be doing that make sure
you use a more recent version of C Mike
alright so the first thing that I want
to talk to you about regarding modern
Semak is usage requirements that's the
idea that a target that you create such
as a library knows what include
directories you have to use in order to
use that library so for example if
you're using cute the cute libraries
know that you need to add - i blah blah
blah cute core to your command line in
order to be able to process and include
cue string so the cute core library
knows that and it needs to communicate
that to all users of cute core so that
concept is what we call a usage
requirement so we've seen this slide
already it's exactly the same as before
I'm defining a library and two
executables and what we might want to do
instead is put those things into into
directories so I've put the libraries
into the libraries directory and the
executables into the executable
directory another question is how can we
make it still work so obviously if hello
dot cpp penn includes salutation dot h
that will work because those two are in
the same directory here once i've moved
them to new directories there's going to
have to be a - i added to the compiled
line so how do we express that well the
old way is to use the include
directories command with some variable
that gets defined somewhere here it's
called salutation includes this is the
old way because it's using the include
directories command and because it's
using a variable I'm going to talk more
in more depth about both of
those issues but a third downside of
this is that it's it's very wordy we
should have a way of lighting our see my
code such that we just don't need that
line at all so another way that we could
write this is we could use the target
include directories command instead of
the include directories command that's a
little bit better because it means that
the include directories are only added
to the target hello and in this case
they're only added to the target goodbye
so you can imagine how long give I could
have different dependencies and they
could have different needs of - I and -
D stuff added to their command command
lines for compilation so this is a bit
more specific to what the need actually
applies to you but it's still wordy like
we don't actually want to specify these
things at all what we want is just to
specify dependency with target linked
libraries and have all of that
compilation requirement magically
determined and that's what modern C make
is really I can go one step further from
this and I can put two colons in there
in the name of the library and this is
maximal maximally modern C Mike at this
point the double colons indicate C make
that this is a target name I'll go into
a little bit more depth about that later
- so when you're writing modern C make
it'll look mostly like this in your in
wherever you define your executables in
your libraries you have at executable or
add add library you'll specify some
sources and then you'll use target link
libraries to specify what the
dependencies are and all of the
dependencies will have some double
colons in them
so what we moved away from is the
include directories command which is not
target specific we want to move to a
target based build system definition
where most of what we're doing is just
expressing dependencies between
different targets we want to have a
single point of dependency specification
so remember that when I defined my
executables I didn't have to explicitly
mention the dependency on the salutation
includes and then also the salutation
library as a link dependency I only have
to specify one thing which was the link
dependency everything else followed and
that's because the targets themselves
provide that information to their
dependents all of the requirements he
needed to compile and Link are built
into the targets themselves so how do we
actually write live salutations such
that that works for those executables
and the way to do that is use the target
include directories command and say that
there's a public requirement to use this
include directory so in this case you
can imagine that salutation dot H lives
in the include subdirectory and that's
the directory that the all depend oh is
need to use so target include
directories anytime that you're using a
command which starts with target there's
a good chance that you're doing the
right thing and using modern seeming
there's a question but so the the remark
is that I don't actually need to write
this ad because dot slash include would
be resolved to
to the current source directory anyway I
think that's true I'm usually explicit
about it but that's also okay yeah
another question okay so the the dog
version maybe before maybe preferred
because it's less wordy it's good point
so there was a keyword there in my use
of target include directories where I
used public I could also have used
private and and interface I have to use
one of those and they each have a
different meaning and you might wonder
what that meaning is so to illustrate
that I have a my class here in my C++
code and it inherits few dependency and
it append includes food dependency now
assuming my classes in my class start H
anyone and including my class start H
will also have to be able to find food a
pendency the file however my class uses
bio dependency internally in the C++
file and the C++ file also includes bar
dependency HSE any dependency which uses
my class H doesn't need to be able to
find bar dependency H so that's why bar
is a private dependency of my class and
fuel is a public dependency and just to
illustrate that with a diagram you can
see that the executable will need to be
able to find food RH but it will not be
a it will not be required to find bar
dot H so that's really the difference
between public and private I also
mentioned interface and that is relevant
mostly just for ahead of only libraries
because it means that a certain
directory is needed for clients but not
for compiling myself so interface might
be a little bit more advanced
so just a summary table there as well to
hammer that point home a little bit it's
something that trips people up a lot
what does public and five it mean it's
my most up voted answer on Stack
Overflow so I kind of think it it must
be relevant somehow to people so we have
a view of modern semuc where you use
target include directories the I also
mentioned these keywords but the thing
is that you can use these keywords on
the content multiple times in one target
target include directories call so you
can make it a little bit less wordy
so just to explore the include
directories command a bit more now
what's so bad about it so for one thing
we know that it affects multiple
libraries at the same time whether or
not that's actually desired another
thing is that order may or may not
matter so in this case when reading this
code you might think well include
directories comes first so that's going
to affect live a and Libby but what if
it comes in the middle is it going to
affect Libby but not live a and he votes
show events he thinks it's going to
affect live a two people three people it
will affect Libby and that's because see
make way back was kind of aiming to be a
bit more declarative and all of the
direct all of the commands that were
created back then affected everything in
the directory so in this case sundar
will be a available to live a or rather
this command on line three will affect
the command on line one
that's also true of course if you put it
at the end so it might make your you
might wonder where certain include
directories are coming a despite order
that you see in your cement code but
that's just how it works
it can get more confusing and
complicated though because now I've I'm
still defining live a but now I'm also
adding subdirectory dr1 then I call
include directories and then I have
another library in another subdirectory
in this case live a is still affected
anything inside of dear one is not
affected and anything inside of dear two
is affected so again it's a bit wild but
you might see even older see my code
which uses the subdues command and if
you see that the content of that is
affected by this include directories
command so I just want to illustrate to
you that if you're using commands like
this that are very old you're going to
get the archaic behavior of Semak which
is not very obvious all of the time
another issue with the include
directories command is that it's not
transitive
we saw some transitivity earlier that
was where an executable depends on a
lively you know which has public and
private dependencies so the includes are
sort of propagated up through the public
edges code which does not use the target
include directories command but uses the
include directories commands instead
tends to have these kind of variables
that are defines so we're saying that
the app includes are a combination of
the live one Lib 2 and 3 includes and
then somewhere down here we you know we
invoke include directories with that so
part of the problem with that is there
could be a great distance between line 8
and line 1
they could be in different sub
directories entirely different parts of
your build system another problem is
this list then has to be maintained it
might be maintained badly there might be
typos libraries might be removed or
added and you could have all kinds of
problems in your build system and again
it's also very wordy so
this case we would be creating a
variable for includes and for libraries
and affecting all of the sub directories
in the app itself so that that gets
unwieldy and that's that was the first
motivation for creating modern C make
way back in 2011 so that was the include
directories command we were talking
about there's another command called add
definitions which has all of the same
drawbacks it works in almost the exact
same way here's a call to it here where
we're defining use internal Cindy and
use multi-threading which you might have
in your build system but an alternative
to that which we have now in modern
Semak is target compile definitions and
that works the exact same way as target
include directories they have the same
design they have the same keywords
public and private and interface and
they work the same way so if you're
looking at code like this which is using
target commands you're looking at modern
seeming so there are other commands as
well which use target prefixes in their
name these two we've looked at already
then there's target compile options for
adding FP I see your warning flags on
either a compile command line option
target link libraries target link
options and target sources so you can
define a target and then later you can
add sources to it the only odd one out
in this list is target link options
because that was created in the last
year all of the other ones have been
around for years so you can already use
them even though this was only created
in the last year it doesn't well there's
a good workaround if you want to use it
but can't because all you have to do is
pass the same arguments to target link
lodges target link libraries is a
command which does a lot of things maybe
too many things which is why targeting
cops
was created but it is a workaround for
the lack of that command if you're using
an even older C Mike yeah well if you
tell anyone I told you this I will deny
all knowledge but you can't actually
redefine commands that are built-in to
see Mike you can override them see if it
were override it with like a fatal error
or something if you wanted but again I
didn't say that yeah you shouldn't do
that really there's a lot of reasons
that you shouldn't but that's just the
answer to your question so just building
up this list of guidelines that I'm
trying to give you there's going to be
about four at the end so we've got the
second one now my target centric code
and mostly that just means he's commands
which have a target prefix oh another
thing which might excite you is there's
a new command just went in to see Mike
last week called target precompiled
headers so I believe it was someone from
the cute company that did that
implemented that for the for the
purposes of cute itself because they
want to be able to define precompiled
headers in their build system easily so
that was yeah that's that was committed
just last week so that's the very latest
and of course it works the same way it
still has public private and interface
keywords the design is being you know
used consistently from the past to the
future so when I talked about the lack
of transitivity I talked about the
resulting need for creating variables
which people do in non-modern C make
that has a few downsides you don't
actually want to rely on variables for
things so here I have a new build system
again I'm defining main sources which
contains just main dot CPP
and then I passed that into our
executable to create up I have an app
includes variable app defines our
libraries and they are not defined in
the same file as this so they're defined
elsewhere so the problem is maybe
because of different ordering of sub
directories or something or somebody
commented something out see make might
see this you know they might see make
might see no content at all the variable
might be treated as not to find or empty
and that's not an error from C make
point of view you know seam variables
can be empty and that's not a problem
but it is a problem for you because
maybe it wasn't intended so what you
should do is try to avoid the use of
variables don't create some kind of
sources variable and populated you know
with different conditions and whatnot
and then at the end call our executable
just try to list all of the sources you
can in our executable directly and then
anything else that you might
conditionally you want to add such as
windows specific sources you can add
them in conditions after I'll be showing
some slides about that in a moment
here as well and listing the libraries
explicitly instead of using a variable
there's there's two points about this is
it possible to use a policy to enforce
that a variable exists no because it is
it is a normal state it makes trouble
it's also relied upon it's like you know
it's like trying to say that C++
shouldn't be dependent on you know based
on C anymore you know there's some
trouble that arises from not but it's
really not worth it to fix it it's
difficult to find those errors I think
maybe the solution is migrate C make
away from the C make language you know
it's a bigger task but
you know in practice there's no way to
do what you're asking I'm afraid mr.
comment over there as well no okay so
yeah there are issues with variables so
you should try to reduce the use of
useless variables and just listings
exactly where they should be
that's because variables are fragile
they leak to other contexts so they leak
into all of your sub directories code
which you may or may not want they don't
have the same scope as your targets so
again they're they're not expressed in
the scope of dependencies under not
checked for correctness or content so I
think that's what your remark was about
that these issues should mean that the
behavior variables should be changed but
there is too much see my code relying on
the existing behavior so that's our
third guideline avoid unnecessary
variables now on to generative
expressions this is a topic which you
might not you might not encounter it in
your first month using modern C make but
you will most likely encounter it after
that so I mentioned before that we want
to avoid using variables so this is what
non modern see make might look like you
might have a variable called main
sources and you have a condition and you
append to that list and at the very end
you create your executable the way to
not use variables in that case is to put
everything after the other executable
line instead of before and use the
target sources command so now I'm not
using any variables so that's already
one step in the right direction another
step in the right direction is I could
actually just list those things in the
other executable call by using this
funny syntax
so this is a generative expression just
to break down a little bit I'm checking
the win32 variable I'm converting that
to a bull so that it's you know 0 1 and
if it's true that if win32 is true then
we use helper window CPP if not when 32
is true then we use helper POSIX CPP now
this sort of stuff you might not want in
the main bulk of your build system you
don't want to be writing it throughout
all of your build system code but what
you can do is to find some helper target
for yourself which abstracts that away a
little bit and then the you know most of
your code will still just be at
executable and target linked libraries
and that's always you go with modern C
make you really only want most of your C
my code to be using three commands are
there are executable or add library and
target linked libraries mostly that's
what you want yeah sorry helper is : :
platform is a target name that's one
single name yeah I'll talk more about
this double : in a minute but it just
indicates the C make that this is a
target name it comes down to the target
link libraries command and how it works
in terms of legacy behavior yeah what
you what to take out of this slide is
that you can create abstraction targets
and then simplify most of your C mate
code just by relying in the target link
libraries command yeah another comment
actually the CPP fights so when I
compile it's not correct so yeah so the
remark is this is a library of sources
so this isn't a compiled library because
I'm using the target sources command
with interface it means we're not going
to build anything ourselves but anything
that depends on this will use these
sources so typically something like this
would be in the same file as this maybe
but it kind of simplifies what hello the
executable does it looks like you can
create a compiled library for that but
I'm kind of trying to illustrate
different ways of specifying sources
which are conditional yeah so the remark
is that this isn't the same as having a
library campaign containing one of these
sources and then linked and that's true
but it is the same as this code in this
code I'm just going to illustrate that
there's other ways of conditionally
making a source file part of a target
yeah ok so this connection you have a
correctness impact on your code as well
you might see this kind of code in non
modern ce mec where you're checking the
see make build type and checking if it's
equal to debugger equal to release this
is non portable because it won't work
with Visual Studio if you've ever used
Visual Studio you know that you launch
it and when you want to build you can
select to build either a debug or
release and that's way after C makers
won so what you need to do is tell C
make that if it's generating for debug
mode use help for debug and if it's not
generating for debug mode use helper
really
so see McDo if it's using Visual Studio
whether you're going to click the debug
button or the release button so you have
to kind of tell it what to do in each
case so it actually generates different
visual studio project files for each
mode and that's how you communicate that
so those generative expressions they get
evaluated after the last line of your
main cmakelists txt file at the top of
your repository or anything like see
make will generate will process your see
make list our text we call that the
configure stage then it'll compute
various things such as which target
depends on which other targets and what
order do I have to build things in in
order to be able to link and then it'll
actually generate the build files and
somewhere in between is where it
processes those generative expressions
and that's helpful because the entire
configuration step has been done already
so I'll tell you a little bit more about
that in a few slides so just to
summarize the basics of generative
expressions 1 : and some content will
result in the content itself 0 : the
content will result in nothing at all
empty config debug will result in one if
it's generating for debug mode and
config debug will result in 0 if it's
not generating for debug mode so by
nesting this one inside of a larger
generative expression we get this and
you can see how it would collapse and
sort of result in the content or not the
content based on basically these two
simple rules and the fact that this
generative expression evaluates to
either 1 or 0
the bool generator expression will have
some truthiness conversion so it'll it's
able to process an empty string for
example if I just put win32 which might
just be empty into a generative
expression it would not be a valid
expression so valid expressions have to
be either 1 or 0 so if I use bull I
convert empty into 0 and that's why this
kind of code can work the a lot of Seema
commands have support for these
generative expressions but not
everything every see make command mostly
that's because the commands were not
relevant to generation but hopefully all
of the needs that you have regarding use
of generative expressions are already
there in your C make version all of the
target commands can use them the file
generate command can use it too that's
something you would use instead of using
file right if if you want to have
different content for debug mode and
release mode that's how you would have a
portable build system to Visual Studio
etc so most of the commands where it's
relevant it's possible to use generative
expressions so just another example of
where that can be relevant in this
little snippet of C make I'm trying to
get the property build with threads on
the target hello sorry I'm trying to get
the property called with threads on the
target hello and I put that into the
variable build with threads and I use
that to try to add a compile definition
use thread so that's used with an F and
F in my C my code and then later I set
the property to on so the problem is
I've set the property to on after trying
to meet it and that's because C make
processes this file from top to bottom
so the alternative way to do it is to
use generator expressions of course
we're saying if the width Reds property
is true on the target specify the used
threads in target compiled definitions
so I appreciate that there's a lot to
unpack in that single line but you do
get used to it and it's quite powerful
once you do and now even though I set
the property to on afterward it doesn't
matter because the setting the property
to on happens in this stage the
configure stage and testing it happens
in the compute stage so that means that
I can't have bugs relating to ordering
of commands inside of my teammate code
and this happens more than you think
because you might have odd subdirectory
calls which change target properties and
later they get red and it might not be
obvious what order things happening so
use generate term conditions correctly
so the probably the last thing I'm going
to have time to talk about is the target
link libraries command I mentioned
before these double colons and target
names and Illustrated that this is what
modern see make looks like when you're
using all modern C make all of your
dependency libraries will have double
columns in them so the reason for that
is the target link libraries command
itself it's very old and it has legacy
behavior for any item that you give it C
make goes to a list of things that that
autumn might be it'll see if that item
is actually a C make target name so
library like live salutation if it's not
a C make target name it'll test whether
it's a library name on there
such as live salutation duress Oh if
that's not true it'll see if it's /opt
/lib salutation daughter so it'll check
if it's a path and if that's not true
it'll treat it as a link or flag and
simply add it to your link line so
that's why you can use target link
libraries with link options such as no
one defined but it also means that if I
make a typo when trying to specify I see
my target name it'll just be added as a
linker flag
so if I have live salute a and that's it
and I forget to write the rest of the
word that'll just be added to my link
line and I won't have a dependency on
that see make target so we we yeah so
this using an item with target link
libraries has a bunch of impacts on you
on your build system it causes a link to
be made on your link line determines
build order so that things are built
before they're linked it consumes usage
requirements such as your dash on your
dash D on your compile command line and
your link options and it determines
compatibility which I won't get into now
but basically you want to try to specify
C make targets where possible instead of
library files or library paths yeah so I
mentioned that if you do make a typo C
make checks what what it could be if
it's a target name etc but otherwise
just adds it to your link liner and you
don't want that so that's why mostly you
want to define targets with double
colons in them that indicates to see
make that order this is a C make target
name or it's an error
so I'm bypassing all of the other
fallback logic that seemed a cascades
through because it always succeeds right
it always gets to a success state of
just added to the link line even though
it's a typo
so if I have targets which have double
colons on their name see make knows that
it must be a target name and if it can't
find a target of that name it gives you
an error so that's why you got cute 5
colon colon core that's why you get
boost colon colon thread etc and you can
do that for your own libraries as well
so there's a number of target types in
see mech the top three are the ones that
you'll use most often
that's executables shared in static
libraries object libraries are quite
similar to static libraries but they
just don't create an archive so it's
just it's just a bunch of object files
interface libraries are used for header
only libraries such as boost MPL and
alias levees are just a way to give
another name to an existing library so
for example I created the lip salutation
library and I would create an alias
called libs colon colon salutation in
order for all of my all of the rest of
my build system to be using target names
with two colons in them yeah
there's the violets on file naming it
you can yeah
sorry can you yeah
so the remark is if I would just create
lib salutation with the colon already I
wouldn't need the alias but that is not
fine unfortunately yes so when you
create an actual build target that
you're building in your build system
like I shared a static library that you
build as opposed to one that you import
it can't have the double colon on it
that's the convention that we came up
with so yeah unfortunately you do need
the alias for that I kind of liked the
idea of making that easier in the future
but it's the case now so I have a few
minutes to talk about dependencies when
you're using external dependencies you
want it to be basically this simple you
do fine package and you use target link
libraries with a target name which
contains two colons some older packages
that you might use might say well first
you call fine package then you call
include directories with few includes
etc but this is what you're aiming for
in terms of simplicity and lack of
redundant commands you simply find
package in there new target link
libraries because this works
transitively in this example I'm calling
fine package for cute five widgets I
have some local library in my build
system and cute five widgets is a public
dependency of the local library also of
hello
that depends only on the local library
but it actually gets the include
directories and everything from cute
five widgets transitively that's because
local Lib uses cute five widgets
publicly so it communicates that through
the public edges all the way up and as I
mentioned the legacy pattern of doing
this kind of thing is very wordy so what
you would have to do with cute well cute
for way back in 2010 you would do
something like this you would call fine
package and then you would use our
definitions throughout all of the - D
definitions then you would use include
directories to add all of the include
directories then you would do some
messing with your cxx flags then you
would have target link libraries with
some variables and then you would set
those variables as dependencies of the
next stuff in your build system so very
worthy lots of stuff to go wrong lots of
potential for typos you don't want to do
any of it so the you know the general
wrong way would be you call fine package
and that provides some variables like
fill include deers few compile
definitions you'll still find a lot of
packages which only provide those kind
of things instead of providing targets
so the aim is that a package that you
use provides a target with a double
colon in the name and of course if I
have this correctly written but I
commentate the fine package or I forget
to write it in the first place so you
make will issue an error because it
knows that this is a target name and a
can't finder so that's useful team
another thing to note that is that
FoodCorps is what we call an imported
library and you can note that that is
similar to the syntax that you would use
for alias levels so again just the
double colons
and I think that's my last guideline
that I had fee which is years into a
imported targets provided by your
dependencies I think the define package
scripts that are provided by C make some
of them provide imported targets like
this but they also provide variables so
in that case you should always prefer to
use the important imported target in
your code I don't think I have yeah
anything else
so the wiki has a lot of outdated
information so I would recommend
avoiding that do you use the
documentation I don't know people Google
things about C make and they find
example code on Stack Overflow and on
github but some of the answers are in
the same accommodation C make mailing
lists also has good activity and Stack
Overflow does too so the people
answering questions on Stack Overflow do
know modern C make and they do advocate
for it shown quite happy but if you do
look at the C make documentation start
here with the C make build system that's
like long-form prose about how to define
your build system similar to this
presentation then you would look at C
make packages that is some documentation
about how to create your own package
files for your libraries so yeah just
thanks some of the ce mec contributor is
in particular brad and pendant pendant
robert and red it also gave me a lot of
feedback for the content of this talk to
you so yeah there's a question
yes so the question is maybe we'll go
back to it yeah so the question is if I
want to make this work how do I do it
and so you would need to use target
include directories but you would also
need to create an alias yeah that's the
easiest way so I don't have that on this
slide but yeah maybe I should have that
on the slide yeah
I don't have any guidance to give about
that so so that the question is about
I'm not sure why people use more than
one use of the project command I'm not
sure if you mean using project inside of
subdirectories yes so the remark is just
about creating a naming convention I
don't have any specific guidance so the
remark is about using dependencies which
don't use cement themselves and use some
other build system you would use the
external project see make module for
that and beyond that you can create your
own targets with double colons in their
name too
make it simple for the rest of your
build system so you mentioned that you
fall back to old C make way which I
guess is variables etc and what you
would do is just take those variables
and define imported targets with those
so you would define an imported target
yourself called this thread say a boost
system and you would define what the
location of the binary is this system
dot a and you would define the include
directories for that as well and then
after that everything else works exactly
like in the presentation yeah and for
examples of that you can look into the
into the interior ce mec distribution
itself if you look in find PNG dot c
maker so that creates an imported target
after you creating the variables and it
just uses those variables yeah mutation
level but in this specific library and
then you have a conflict about you know
you don't want global variables but you
also would like to have a default level
and so how do you how do you have a
default global warning level for example
and be able to reduce that in some
specific target you can do some messing
with target properties like I showed in
the slides and then I generate time have
some generator expression specifying
which one to use but yeah that gets to
advanced topics then as well yeah I
think we have time for one more question
yeah
I proposed well on my own let's see
this is a cute paste text processing
library that I have and then I maintain
for now it's just got two libraries
inside of it so it's using a lot of
modern CMake techniques there's a bad
example but yeah so you know using
target compiled features it's actually
doing a lot of wrong things but I hope
it's using cute 5 : : qml so that's good
but yeah maybe look at the KDE libraries
as well they're using modern CMake and
cute as well so it could be a good one
to look at okay thanks for coming
[Applause]